if you're looking for a technique that
can give you an edge in the gym then
weighted stretching might just be it so
a weighted stretching is one of those
things that does what it says on the tin
it's exactly what it sounds like it
means that you're stretching whilst
holding weights or whilst under some
form of resistance so this usually means
just going through a much larger range
of motion on your exercise allowing
yourself to move into that point where
you're feeling the stretch and it kind
of hurts and a lot of people think that
including this into your training can
drastically increase hypertrophy maybe
even cause muscle hyperplasia meaning
that you're creating new muscle cells so
one of the reasons that people believe
this is because of a study that was
conducted on birds
quails to be precise I don't know why
quails they were taken and for around 28
days or longer than another version of
the study they had weights hung from
their wings constantly so they were in
constant agony it's not the most humane
of studies and then following this they
were killed and their wings were cut
open and they had their muscle fibers
counted so that's also charming what
they found was that increased muscle
size by 300% and that it caused
significant muscle hyperplasia the
creation of new muscle fibers so
normally our muscles grow larger because
our muscle fibers our muscle cells are
thickening but in this case they also
created brand-new muscle fibers as well
as the regular form of hypertrophy we
don't know for certain whether humans
are even capable of experiencing muscle
hyperplasia the evidence on that is
somewhat contradictory I tend to fall on
the side that I think we probably can
but it seems as though if anything's
going to trigger it it might be weighted
stretching the cynical of you might have
noticed that there are some problems
with this study for one other than the
whole moral aspect it was conducted on
birds so you know not human subjects
weren't necessarily not everything that
bird does a human should do got to meet
the
there sir I think he's a chicken also
this study was thirty days of pure
torture which you're not gonna be able
to do to your own arms and you might
also think that surely any form of
training that lasted literally thirty
days straight solidly would have some
kind of massive impact on muscle growth
so that alone probably isn't enough
evidence for us to think that weighted
stretching is the the new holy grail of
weight training however a more recent
study has looked at the effect that
weight is stretching could have on
regular human folk and found that by
introducing a weighted stretching
protocol into calf raises they saw
significant increases in muscle
hypertrophy and muscle size though not
necessarily in terms of muscle strength
but what's actually more interested in
this case is the huge amount of
anecdotal evidence supporting weighted
stretching so our knee for instance used
two weighted stretching and if you watch
pumping iron you can see him on the
dumbbell flyes his his arm go almost all
the way back and he talks about creating
a stretch and really building more pump
that way I personally find that when I
go to the gym if I'm getting towards the
end of a set and I'm starting to feel
myself fatigued I'm starting to feel
that muscle damage then I intuitively
stretch the muscle I've been doing this
for a long time I'll ensure tively
stretch into that and even because I can
feel that it's creating the right kind
of pump there's gonna signal growth
later on so the same kind of sensation I
get from swelling the muscle through
high rep ranges which would correlate as
well it makes sense if this is something
that increases hypertrophy not
necessarily strength
so alpha Destiny also did a video on
this topic and he talked about the huge
amount of anecdotal evidence for
weighted stretching he talked in
particular about how those exercises
that are well known for being very
effective at triggering growth in
stubborn muscle groups or specific areas
tend to involve a stretching component
so for instance he talked about how
doing weighted pull-ups is great for
building up the lats he talked about how
doing the farmers walk with a trap
buyers from tastic for triggering growth
in the traps both these things involve a
large stretching component it's well
known that dumbbell flies whether or not
you think they are potentially damaging
to the shoulders that's also up for
debate but it's well known that they are
fantastic for growing the chair
probably because there's a stretching
element there you can also use cable
flyes of course for the same effect if
you're not a fan of dumbbell flyes I
personally find them fine listen to your
body so why might weight and stretching
be effective well there's a few
different explanations no one can quite
agree once again one popular explanation
is that you're stretching the fashio the
surrounding connective tissue around the
muscle belly and this is allowing it to
grow bigger it's creating the more space
for your muscle to grow that was one of
the most popular older explanations as
to why it might work it makes sense to
me as well that simply stretching the
muscle might cause more muscle damage it
has an occlusion effect meaning that
it's gonna trap more blurbs and more
oxygen and nutrients in the muscle for
longer it's also been suggested that it
might increase igf-1 production or mTOR
signaling so there's lots of potential
explanations and it's also possible that
it's all of these combined giving you
that really impressive effect that a lot
of people report from their own
experience so there's not a ton of
scientific evidence but there's a lot of
anecdotal evidence a lot of people swear
by weight and stretching and the
evidence that we do have the research
that we do have looks promising so far
so to me that's enough reason to
incorporate weighted stretching into my
program and what's also very interesting
is that this might be a good way to
improve your mobility firstly it gives
you a great way to train your mobility
if you're suddenly just fine stretching
boring I talked about this in my video
on black panther training how if you
wanted to stretch more and improve your
mobility but you're not somebody
particularly enjoys wasting time rolling
around on a map then you can just use
stretching whilst you're exercising so
for instance stretching your calves
during your calf raises at the same time
though this might be actually more
effective increasing flexibility than
regular stretching even because it's
very similar to something called PNF
stretching that's proprioceptive
neuromuscular facilitation and this
basically means that when you're
stretching you you go into your stretch
position hold the position as normal but
then you also contract the muscle and
contract in some cases the antagonistic
muscle and what has been found in many
different studies is that this actually
increases your flexibility more quickly
more effectively than regular stretching
i've had a few different explanations as
to why this might be effective one is
that the contraction is overriding the
pain the new susceptor feedback that
normally prevents you from stretching
further it
basically changes the signal coming from
the Golgi tendon organ it's also
possible I would think that simply by
contracting the muscle you're actually
increasing the stretch slightly further
than you can do simply by pushing
yourself into that position because
you're placing extra resistance onto the
connective tissue
whatever the case there if PNF
stretching is more effective than
regular stretching then it follows that
using weighted stretching might also be
particularly effective as a way to
increase your mobility as well as your
strength so how might you use weighted
stretching in your own program or
there's a few different options and
different people approach it differently
like I say the jury is still out on this
topic but one of the most popular
options is to simply place a 30 second
weighted stretch at the end of your last
set on whichever exercise and by doing
this it's apparently more effective
because you've already got a pump you've
already got some occlusion going on so
you'll finish your set and then just
hold that isometric position contracting
the muscle as you do not bobbing just
letting it pull you into that really
painful stretch position it does hurt
another option is simply to perform your
regular exercise as Arnie does on his
dumbbell fly but to go into a larger
range of motion that's what I tend to do
I often will put it kind of all over the
place but obviously this is quite
fatiguing so you want to think about
what you're going to do next and not
ruin your performance on your next
exercise other than that it's pretty
much fair game and of course you can
also include PNF stretching after your
workouts instead of just regular
stretching where you do this like I say
it is stretching to the best position
you want to be in and then hold that
position and contract the muscle PNF
stretching is also a great option for
stretching muscles that are harder to
stretch with other exercises because
some make a lot of sense and exercises
very naturally lend themselves to
stretching like the dumbbell fly like
seated dumbbell curls or decline
dumbbell curls like pull-ups just hangs
hands are also great for your grip hands
are fantastic in fact I might do a whole
video on them like squats if you go well
below parallel or leg press however
other exercises other muscle groups are
more difficult to target and in that
case using PNF stretching might make
more sense as a second best alternative
and of course I'm not saying you should
do this in every single workout I'm not
even saying you'll necessarily work for
you but I think it works for me I
incorporate it in a kind of loose and
should manage us when I feel like it
when I'm aiming for pump and maybe you
can give it a go and see how it works
for you and if you have tried it I'd
love to hear what you think in the
comments down below so advanced video
useful interesting guys if you did then
please leave a like please share it
around helps me out so much please
comment down below like I say let me
know what you think and stay tuned if
you want more on bodybuilding Fitness
mobility parkour martial arts technology
transhumanism productivity psychology
nootropics
you name it if that sounds good then
thanks a ton for watching and I'll see
you next time
bye for now